this is 28 year old Andrew banks from
Stansted in Essex he was attending that
protest in Parliament Square a protest
that was designed we're told to protect
statues and monuments around that
Parliament Square area but this young
man said that he had no idea what
monuments he was actually guarding and
that he was with a group of football
lads Alliance one of a number of groups
including right-wing groups who were at
this protest in Parliament Square he had
consumed 16 pints overnight and into
Saturday morning when he arrived in the
square apparently he said he was very
drunk his legal team told Westminster
magistrates court that he had no idea
what he was doing when he was
photographed urinating next to the
memorial of PC Keith Palmer that police
officer who was martyred outside
Parliament as he tried to protect the
houses of parliament from a terrorist
attacker in March of 2017 and of course
the images went into the press and on
social media gained a lot of traction
and resulted in a lot of revulsion as
well to bias elwood the Conservative MP
who had gone to try in vain to help PC
Keith Palmer on the day he was attacked
said that he found the images abhorrent
and in court today the senior magistrate
Emma Arbuthnot who sentenced this young
man to 14 days in jail said that she
accepted that he was drunk that he was
genuinely remorseful and didn't realize
what he was doing but that the was such
widespread revulsion of what he had done
that she had no choice but to jail him
for two weeks he's now being taken down
into custody and will serve as I say two
weeks in prison for that offence
it looks like he might have got off
quite lightly given that the government
wants to introduce 10 years possibly for
defiling monuments
well certainly I mean I think as far as
the charges concerned Emma Arbuthnot was
going off previous charges about
reaching public decency and it was felt
that a month reduces to two weeks
because he had come forward and admitted
to the offense when his father
confronted him after these images were
widely circulated he admitted it as I
see he claimed that he had no idea what
he was doing so mr bath Mort basing or
sentencing on previous similar cases
came up with this 14 days in custody but
you're right there are other people who
have still to go through the court
system and remember there are people
that have defaced statues and other
monuments as well who have still to face
court proceedings so it will be
interesting to find out what sentences
they get in the weeks ahead